.
AND THE U.S. BELIEVES THE ATTACK
THAT SHUT DOWN SEVERAL MEAT
PACKING PLANTS DID COME FROM
RUSSIA.
A LOT AT STAKE HERE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M FASCINATED BY SOMETHING YOU
TOLD OUR PRODUCER, WHICH IS YOU
BELIEVE PERHAPS THE CYBERATTACKS
ARE GOING ON RIGHT NOW, BUT THE
U.S. ISN'T DISCLOSING MANY
DETAILS, THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO
CONFLICT TO ESCALATE.
CAN YOU TELL US MORE ABOUT THAT?
>> YEAH, SO WE SEE A VERY
INTERESTING SITUATION THAT
HAPPENED.
WE CAN START ALL THE WAY FROM
LAST YEAR, AS YOU DESCRIBED, IT
WAS A MASSIVE YEAR WHEN IT COME
TO CYBERATTACK, ALL THE WAY TO
SOLAR WIND, JBS, COLONIAL
PIPELINE.
ALL THOSE TYPE OF HACKS CAME
FROM RUSSIA, SPECIFICALLY FROM
THE RANSOMWARE CARTEL THAT'S
HAPPENING THERE.
IN JANUARY THIS YEAR, BASICALLY
THE MAIN CARTEL, OUR EVIL GROUP,
HAS BEEN ARRESTED BY THE
RUSSIAN, AND SINCE THAT POINT IN
TIME WE BASICALLY STOPPED SEEING
ATTACK WHEN IT COMES TO
RANSOMWARE.
IT'S BECOME VERY, VERY QUIET.
WE BELIEVE THOSE GROUP HAVE BEEN
RECRUITED TO SERVE AND SWITCH
FROM BEING A STATE IGNORED GROUP
TO BEING STATE CONTROLLED.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT RIGHT NOW
THOSE GROUPS ARE GOING TO START
BEING OPERATIONALIZED IN THE
U.S. SPECIFICALLY TO START
ATTACKING.
AND TO BE HONEST, IN THE PAST
FEW WEEKS WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
AN ESCALATION OF MORE AND MORE
ATTACKS THAT ENDED UP WITH THE
PRESIDENT SAYING, HEY,
EVERYBODY, YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE
THAT THIS IS GOING TON AND YOU
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT
VERY, VERY QUICKLY.
>> WHAT WOULD BE THE KEY TARGETS
OF THOSE ATTACKS?
>> YEAH, SO IF YOU'RE GOING BACK
TO LAST YEAR, IT WAS ONE BIG
ESPIONAGE ATTACK THAT I DON'T
BELIEVE GOING TO BE KIND OF THE
MAIN PUSH FROM THE RUSSIA SIDE
OF THE HOUSE.
AND BASICALLY RANSOMWARE AND THE
ABILITY TO CREATE THE PUSH OR
PRESSURE ON THE ECONOMY IN THE
U.S., THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE IS GOING TO START
HAPPENING SPECIFICALLY AFTER THE
SANCTION THAT'S STARTING TO
BECOME MORE AND MORE EFFECTIVE
INSIDE RUSSIA.
SO I BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IS MORE RANSOMWARE
ATTACK HERE IN THE U.S., MORE
TARGETED RANSOMWARE.
THE JOB IS TO CREATE PRESSURE ON
A PRIVATE COMPANY, AND BY DOING
IT, IT'S BASICALLY CREATE THE
PRESSURE ON THE GOVERNMENT HERE
IN THE U.S.
>> IN TERMS OF THAT PRESSURE,
THOUGH, DO YOU THINK THAT THEY
WOULD ESCALATE FURTHER TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD ATTACK
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, WHETHER
YOU'RE TALK ABOUT WATER
TREATMENT PLANTS, OR AS CNN JUST
LEARNED, THE FACT THAT THEY WERE
SCANNING SOME OF THOSE ENERGY
COMPANIES?
OR EVEN SOMETHING LIKE, GOOD
FORBID, LOOKING AT BANKS AS
TARGETS.
>> YEAH, SO I THINK THAT FROM
THEIR POINT OF VIEW, THERE IS NO
SECTOR THAT'S OFFLIMIT, AND WE
SAW IT LAST YEAR, ALL THE WAY
FROM MEAT PACKING COMPANY JBS TO
THE COLONIAL PIPELINE THAT HAS
BEEN HACKED AND BASICALLY
SUPPLIED THE OIL AND GAS TO THE
EAST COAST.
WE KNOW THAT THE FINANCIAL
SECTOR IS GETTING HIT ALL THE
TIME.
WE KNOW THAT OUR FINANCIAL
SECTOR HERE IN THE U.S. IS
FAIRLY PROTECTED AND USING
MODERN TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER MAKE
SURE THEY ARE PROTECTED.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE UTILITIES
COMPANIES GENERALLY SPEAKING ARE
LESS PROTECTED AND LESS
RESOURCED IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THIS TYPE OF ATTACK.
SO ABSOLUTELY, WE BELIEVE THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO WAIT AND CHOOSE
AND PICK WHAT THEY ARE HACKING.
THEY'RE GOING TO GO AFTER
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
>> IN TERMS OF INDIVIDUALS OR
EVEN SMALL BUSINESSES -- AND I
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THESE CLICHES
ALL THE TIME, BUT WHAT CAN WE DO
TO MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T AFFECT
US?
>> YEAH, SO I THINK THERE IS
BASIC STEPS THAT EVERYBODY CAN
APPLY, ALL THE WAY FROM IF YOU
GET AN SMS, YOU DON'T KNOW FROM
WHERE YOU GET IT, OR AN EMAIL
WITH THE LINK, DON'T PRESS THE
LINK.
IGNORING SMS AND SOCIAL
ENGINEERING TECHNIQUES, THIS IS
THE ABILITY TO LURE YOU TO CLICK
SOMETHING TO HAVE ACCESS TO YOUR
COMPUTER OR PHONE.
IF YOU BASICALLY PAY ATTENTION
TO THOSE THINGS, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT MAKES -- THAT IS
VERY, VERY EFFECTIVE, TO BE
HONEST, IN MANY CASES AS AN
INDIVIDUAL.
WHEN IT COMES TO COMPANIES, I
THINK THAT COMPANIES HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT THEY HAVE TO START
REALIZE USING NOT A TECHNOLOGY
LIKE THEY USED TO LIKE FIRE
WALLS AND ANTIVIRUS AND
MODERNIZE TH